on passe au panel politique avec michel
serrault g michel david et à laquelle
sont qui conçoivent ou trois
bons alors aujourd'hui c'était le fameux
plan présenté par les ministres la santé
monsieur dubé il était accompagné du
premier ministre legault de madame
lebaye du conseil du trésor pour nous
expliquer par quel baguette magique
qu'ils ont on va pas assez pour réussir
à attirer 4000 300 infirmières de retour
dans le réseau comment on va faire
gonfler les rangs des gens qui
travaillent à temps plein on est quand
un extrait de monsieur legault on note
très bien compris que l'essentiel pour
les infirmières c'est pas l'argent c'est
la qualité de vie c'est d'être capable
d'arrêter d'avoir du temps
supplémentaire obligatoire d'avoir la
prévisibilité faut que réseau public de
la santé soit la meilleure place pour
les infirmières pour travailler
monsieur legault dire c'est pas l'argent
mais essentiellement on a parlé d'argent
on avançait un milliard de dollars avec
des primes de toutes sortes qui vont
jusqu'à 10000 dollars de plus sur un an
est ce qu'on ne trouve parler d'argent
avec ce c'est le plan de la carotte que
le gouvernement mis en place des camps
on a fait le bon constat c'est pas un
problème d'argent c'est surtout un
problème de travail mais on espère que
l'argent règle les problèmes de
conditions de travail en espagne avait
suffisamment qui passent du temps
partiel ou temps plein ou qui reviennent
dans les réseaux soient du privé ou soit
deux des frères à la retraite pour qu'on
puisse donc avoir des meilleures
conditions travail qui est moins
d'heures supplémentaires obligatoires
qui soit la prévisibilité des horaires
soient plus soit plus simple est ce que
ça va fonctionner ça c'est la grande
question il ya aucune aucun bâton dans
ce plan là on ne contraint pas vraiment
les agences privées et quoi que ce soit
on veut donner les meilleurs aux
horaires aux infirmières du réseau
public et arrêter de donner les horaires
les plus agréables aux agences privées
60 semble une bonne idée mais au-delà de
ça
tout le reste là on est sur la bonne foi
on espère que les intervient revienne si
on espère qu'elle convertissent leurs
postes à temps partiel si ça fonctionne
tant mieux ça va être une excellente
nouvelle un acte de foi un acte de foi
l'impression d'un château de cartes 11
ici tout va bien on va avoir un
magnifique château mais les bases
restent fragiles faut que tout
fonctionne pour pas qu'on manque un
étage michel david le dessus en quoi
rajouter autant d'argent à meilleur dans
les faits des conditions de travail des
infirmières
quand on leur parle elle nous parle de
conditions de travail pas d'argent oui
mais je pense qu'avec le très bien
expliqué les conditions de travail
s'amélioreront pas il y aura pas moins
de temps supplémentaire obligatoire il y
aura pas des meilleurs ratios si un peu
plus de monde dans le système et la
façon d'amener du monde c'est de les
payer alors ça peut sembler mercantile
comme approche mais honnêtement je vois
pas tellement ce que le gouvernement
pourrait faire d'autres maintenant
j'admets que ça prend un gros acte de
foi
et de façon générale de questions de la
santé on est tellement habitué à ce que
rien ne marche quand on dit tout ça
marche repos mais est-ce que le
gouvernement va être capable d'aller
chercher ses 4300 je pense infirmière
qui veut amener dans le réseau a même si
on avait juste 2000 ce serait déjà ça de
pris alors on va le savoir en bout de
ligne mais je conçois que c'est ça prend
un acte de foi mais je vois pas trop
comment on peut prendre l'a6 et la
cadrature du cercle l'a fait la pole il
faut commencer quelque part alors on
commence par le snec michel fait
on peut pas blâmer les pompiers le
vouloir éteindre le feu est ce que le
gouvernement essaie de faire aujourd'hui
cdthed façon c'est pas des boyaux
d'arrosage ses boyaux d'argent et c'est
ce qu'ils essaient de faire pour le
reste c'est pas sûr que ça fonctionne ça
peut peut-être fonctionner mais c'est le
seul moyen qu'ils aient quelques le
gouvernement à sa disposition mais il y
avait des infirmières aujourd'hui qu'ils
disent écoutez là ils veulent conduire à
temps plein mais beaucoup d'infirmières
se sont mis d'accords partiels justement
pour avoir un meilleur contrôle sur
leurs horaires un peu plus de qualité
alors le cir entre-temps plaît ils vont
tomber dans tâches supplémentaires
obligatoires encore une fois c'est ce
qui essayait dé dj
aussi le poulet un oeuf là qui
risque de coincer les mots que madame
bédard le président de l'afic disait
vous savez c'est la foulée poule là
dedans on comprend bien mais finalement
la poule pas son jour en dernis d'une
certaine façon madame bédard quand on
lui parle d'acte de foi voici ce qu'elle
a à dire
est ce qu'on à l'extraire faire jouer
l'extrait de mme bédard bon alors on n'a
pas l'extrait pour les ça en dit que ça
s'en vient chez ce type de patients aux
actes de fois encore est ce que les
professionnelles en soins qui on a vite
quitté ou celles qui ont quitté auront
assez confiant sur la base des principes
et sur la base monétaire killer de cake
qu'on leur offre aujourd'hui de se dire
je vais revenir parce que de cette fois
ci j'ai confiance de temps
supplémentaire obligatoire ça va prendre
une décision à un moment donné ça fait
15 ans qu'on vit avec stop c'est juste
exponentielle ça va prendre un
engagement une décision une déclaration
claire qu'il ne sera plus utilisée
on comprend que pour madame bédard qui
représente quand même un bon nombre
d'infirmières il n'y a pas de confiance
sur n'y a pas d'acte de foi en réalité
elle elle aurait voulu un engagement où
on dit écoute et à quelle date elle
conditions ou à telle date là il y en eu
plus de temps supplémentaire obligatoire
si le morceau qui manque qu on al
impression dans les fils de monsieur
dubé elec
oui mais je pense que le gouvernement
n'est pas capable de dire ça on le
comprend bien à moyen terme on veut en
arriver là d'ailleurs
temps
supplémentaire obligatoire qui essaient
en double il le répéter mais on n'est
pas capable de donner de date parce que
le réseau va tellement mal qu'on va
probablement être capable
on espère être capable d'améliorer les
choses avant de pouvoir donner des
garanties dans toute la conférence de
presse le autant de lorsqu'on a parlé
d'argent que de 3000 argent comblant
embauché l'agent administratif pour
aider les infirmiers il y avait
plusieurs idées intéressantes on sait
pas ce qu'il va fonctionner moi ce que
j'ai trouvé peut-être le plus rassurant
pour les infirmières c'est que christian
dubé jeudi je vais m'en occuper
personnellement je vais mettre un comité
de suivi la tue chaque jour je me posais
des questions aux pdg des cieux je veux
que ça s'améliore quand christian dubé
dit ça pour la vaccination il y aurait
eu si à sa campagne de vaccination
précédemment généralement c'est
quelqu'un de très impliqués qui peut
être assez ferme avec le réseau de la
santé qui lui en fait une priorité
peut-être que ça des chances de
fonctionner on al'impression quitte à se
déterminer mais faudra effectivement là
que tout les toutes les pièces du pas au
top en place le sait rapidement pour que
cela fonctionne il est quand même
effectivement une certitude la
difficulté là dedans est ce que monsieur
dubé ne contrôle pas c'est que les
infirmières elles ont le choix peuvent
aller travailler dans une agence privée
à peuvent aller travailler en ontario
alors ça ça dépend essentiellement
d'elle je comprends très bien la
réaction de la présidente de madame
bédard et dirige un syndicat et sa job
c'est de faire pression sur le
gouvernement mais a comprend très bien
la problématique le score ce qu'on se
dit lol elle sait plus que nous alors ça
la balle est dans le camp des
infirmières très honnêtement mais on
veut vraiment rendre beaucoup plus
alléchants travailler dans le public
quand c'est ce qui a été expliqué
aujourd'hui c'est à dire on va vous
offrir d'abord et vous les meilleurs
horaires et non pas à celles qui sont
issues des agences privées on vous offre
des primes qui vont est plus avantageuse
que les primes que l'ontario vient vous
offrir par les fonds du maraudage pour
essayer de vous amener finalement dans
leur système en eux alors c'est quand
même un milliard de dollars c'est
beaucoup d'argent c'est des primes que
monsieur madame tout le monde au port
habituellement dans son année de travail
est-ce que ça mais pas justement un peu
de pression sur les infirmières parce
qu'on voit l'effort quand même du
gouvernement michel c oui mais en même
temps le problème c'est qu'ils manquent
4300 infirmières et je pense qu'on peut
qu'il y autant d'infirmières retraitées
que ça qui a effectivement vouloir
retenir pour 15 dollars je pense sûr
qu'il ya tant de gens qui vont tout et
les agences pour revenir dans le secteur
public pour qui est ce maintenant c'est
ça qui est qui qui est le problème de
quoi j'ai eu très peur car j'ai entendu
monsieur de vous parler du succès de la
campagne de recrutement des préposés aux
bénéficiaires c'est pas du tout la même
chose on pouvait reformé l'api demande
est proposée au prix aux bénéficiaires
on peut pas faire ça avec internet c'est
bien évident 3 4 5 1 alors ya vraiment
une grosse différence là et c'est pour
ça que le résultat final est pas
garantie ouais et l'autre l'autre
histoire aussi parce que là on est on
est dans un décompte on est à 12
semaines à peu près le du 15 octobre qui
est la date d'application la vaccination
obligatoire pour les gens qui
travaillent dans le monde de la santé
avec le risque de perdre davantage de
gens monsieur dubé nous apprenait
aujourd'hui encore 7500 personnes dans
le réseau de la santé qui sont pas
vaccinés sont aussi avec ça peut faire
un gros trou dans les horaires
oui bah oui encore des gens qui ont le
temps de se faire vacciner pour
convaincre le gouvernement si la
personne a reçu sa première dose et qui
a longuement actuellement quelques jours
au mas quelle est sa deuxième relais
seront pas suspendus sans solde on va
leur permettre d'aller chercher leur
deuxième dose c'est pas tout des
infirmières aussi 7700 personnes le jan
ader toutes sortes de corps de métier
dont on
pense qu'on est capable de s'en sortir à
court terme il ya un peu
une partie de poker qui joue là dessus
il est bien des employés qui veulent pas
se faire vacciner dix ans le
gouvernement a tellement besoin de nous
que ils vont me laisser trois ou quatre
jours à la maison qui va nous rappeler
le gouvernement dit ben non on retenait
notre boue qui ça va être plusieurs
semaines qu'on resserre angers qui va
avoir raison ça on le verra on verra un
peu plus tard dans le cas des infirmiers
je veux juste terminer en disant qu'il
ne manque pas en nombre d'infirmières au
québec il ya plus d'infirmières par
habitant au québec qui en ontario et
sait seulement qu'elle ne sont pas au
bon endroit soit elles font du travail
administratif ou soit qu'elles sont dans
le réseau privé il ya des infirmières à
la retraite qui peuvent certainement
revenir je pense que c'est costaud c'est
d'en ramener quelques milliers 4300 je
sais pas 2000 3000 comme le disait
michel la vie ça se peut que ce soit
possible mais dans combien de temps le
feu ait pris lol ainsi ils reviennent
dans trois ou quatre mois ça se peut
qu'elle soit trop tard et c'est ce qu'il
faut que ça répond vite à cet appel mais
c'est un peu le résultat de toutes les
années passées à michel david parce
qu'on attendait monsieur legault dire là
c'est le temps qu'on prenne soin des
infirmières mais par le passé j'ai
l'impression qu'on mettait tous les ans
prenait soin des médecins et on a pris
beaucoup soins des médecins et on a tenu
pour un qui les infirmières oui mais oui
c'est vrai dans une certaine mesure mais
il faut bien dire aussi que la la façon
de négocier des conventions collectives
au québec c'est compliqué c'est à dire
que depuis toujours les cendres les
centrales syndicales ont refusé
d'accepter des augmentation différenciée
si les infirmières on lui donnait 5 % il
fallait que tout le monde dans le
secteur public parapublic et 5% et à
partir de ce moment là et chaque point
d'augmentation coûte une fortune au
gouvernement à partir du moment où on
accepte le principe qu'il ya des gens
dont on veut valoriser le travail vont
avoir des augmentations
plus importantes
là on commence à voir le début d'une
solution ça peut prendre du temps mais à
partir du moment où ce principe le est
établi et cette fois ci c'est il faut
quand même rendre à césar ce qui
appartient le gouvernement legault ont
réussi à convaincre les centrales
d'embarquer là dedans et ça c'est majeur
alors ce qu'on comprend finalement c'est
que c'est la période difficile leur
monsieur legault disait c'est une
passerelle qu'on essaie de bâtir pour se
rendre jusqu'à l'application la
convention collective il reste encore
des négociations locales
on comprendre que cette convention
collective où on ne réussit à voir des
gains avoir des salaires différents
selon la difficulté de l'horaire qu'on
va établir donc je le fais avec vous
confiant qu'on va éviter de nouvelles
ruptures de service que qui va avoir au
moins une partie de ce plan là qui va
donner des résultats
mettez le feu ait pris est ce qu'on va
réussir les perdre avec ça on ne sait
pas le global c'est beau lui-même il
fait son meilleur effort mais il ne sait
pas lui-même alors les dérivés des
ruptures de services à court terme non
il semble en profiter et d'autres pans
du gouvernement prodi non il y en aura
pas de rupture de s'adresser pas promis
ça c'était aujourd'hui je patine seule
conférence de presse non alors je pense
qu'ils savent eux-mêmes que c'est une
situation extrêmement périlleuse et donc
c'est le mot europe est ce qu'il peut
avec les moyens qu'ils n'ont ils ont mis
les gros moyens sur la table évidence
quand même pas rien
autre sujet qui retient l'attention
aujourd'hui qui est toujours en cours
d'ailleurs c'est ce projet de loi pour
interdire les manifestations à moins 50
mètres de tout ce qui est garderies
écoles notre collègue valérie gamache
disait qu'on ne rajoute les cegep là
dedans aussi les centres de vaccination
les hôpitaux il y avait un difficile
équilibre à trouver entre le droit de
manifester est éloigné finalement les
antilles wechsel
des jeunes essentiellement et des gens
qui travaillent dans le monde de la
santé et c'est prenez l'accord de tout
le monde est là qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais c'est mieux que même un peu
étonné qu'il ait pas plus de résistance
aujourd'hui de la part de claire samson
ce parti conservateur
c'était elle qui était un peu le joker
dans le jeune homme qu'est ce qu'elle
allait faire finalement lady belge
accepte de que le projet de loi soit
déposé mais je vais en parler plus
longtemps je vais pas avoir seulement
une minute 27 de temps parole selon la
procédure qui aurait pu être mis en
place le gouvernement décide
effectivement et tirer plus longtemps
les débats le gouvernement à écouter les
partis d'opposition à québec c'est
évident à trouver que on devrait
renouveler au 30 jours par exemple
ce décret là plutôt que de la coller à
l'aube gens solitaires au décret
d'urgence sanitaire on l'écouté parti
libéral voulait étendre son au cégep ou
post secondaire on l'écouté on va la
jouer comme amendement donc le
gouvernement était assez réceptifs aux
commentaires des autres parties pour qu
on puisse donc aller de l'avant s'est
rapidement fait en collant un peu
l'esprit du projet de loi ce qui avait
été fait en 2016 concernant les
cliniques d'avortement dans les mêmes
termes qui sont repris les mêmes
dispositions 50 mètres de distance on
peut pas intimidé on peut pas découragé
quelqu'un de se faire vacciner en soit
si ou à l'époque d'aller se faire
avorter le comme ç'avait été adoptée
l'unanimité en 2016 par les parties il
ça devenait compliqué de deux points
d'accord avec ça donc je pense qu'on a
assez bien manoeuvré le du côté du
gouvernement pour que ce soit adoptée il
peut-être même dès ce soir la pensée
pour m oui
pour venir en aide à mme samson et à
monsieur duhaime savez monsieur duhaime
lui la cci intentions de vote se sont
dopés si vous voulez parler les
manifestants lui les opposants mais un
jour ça va finir ça et je pense que
monsieur duhaime aimerait quand même
élargir un petit peu sa base et 6
étaient opposés ou qu'ils avaient essayé
de saboter ce projet de loi là les gens
l'auraient l'aurait retenu et il serait
dit après le conseil toi le degré de
responsabilité ou d'irresponsabilité
quelque peu atteint alors je pense qu'il
a il a bien fait en se disant bon
collaborons parce que autrement on
compromet notre propre avenir
là dessus
je veux juste souligner une ironique
voici un projet de loi ou une
utilisation de la clause dérogatoire de
la constitution était tout à fait
approprié on l'a fait de façon
préventive dans le projet de loi sur la
langue alors que c'est pas vraiment
nécessaire ça va plus être très
approprié effectivement de dire le droit
de manifester d'un droit fondamental oui
mais il ya quand même quelque chose de
fondamental les écoles les centres de
vaccination etc être ouvert et ne pas
avoir déjà qu'ils estimaient déjà qui va
se présenter
mais bon on a choisi une autre voie
merci à vous tous pour ce panel au
revoir au revoir